here to respond is rudy guiliani
president Trump's personal attorney and
former New York City Mayor Mayor I've
never been to this facility where this
only I watch it being built really so
how could this happen
I was an assistant US attorney when they
built it I was a US attorney who
occupied the building next to it it's
connected to the US Attorney's Office so
when we moved I watched it being built
and when I was there I had a window that
looked right into the MCC and I've been
in it probably 20 times as a prosecutor
and as a defense lawyer well I wish
somebody normally thought they were
looking at a window nobody was ability
and I know I know the four they're
talking about and I don't like
conspiracy theories I don't think we
should engage them yet because we need
to know the facts but the whole thing is
completely incredible to me and I just
spent the night having dinner with two
corrections officials who know that in
places intimately as I do and they can't
figure out how this could possibly have
happened how you could let a guy who's
the most high risk prisoner in the
facility who could be killed for several
reasons he could kill himself right
prisoners could kill him because they
don't like perverts alleged perverts
right and they don't like people who
might cooperate which he seemed like he
might be a guy finally that could be
people from the outside who would reach
the people on the inside to kill him so
he had three reasons why this guy should
be protected he was virtually
unprotected so the irregularities are
fueling the conspiracy theories because
now there's a rapport they're true well
right I mean there's a report that some
other crazy crazy stuff right I mean but
do you suspect there could have been
foul play
so if I were investigating it I'd have
to indulge all those theories right I
have I'd have to consider he committed
suicide or they would negligent or they
were complicit or prisoners came in and
killed him but they didn't really care
whether that happened so I don't know
which of those four possibilities exist
I have tremendous confidence in attorney
general bar this facility wasn't
something he would have been able
to really manage the short time he's
been there and it's I remember that
facility as being one of the most secure
facilities in America
I put mafia cooperated Sicilian Mafia
co-operators terrorists in there never
had a problem with them because it was
so well managed what happened to him I
do not understand I'll give you an
example they put him in a place with a
bunk bed mm-hmm
so what can't do it a bunk bed you can
take that you can take a sheet you can
hang it up on the higher bunk and you
can hang yourself you should be in a
facility with a flat bed right so you
can't as easily hang yourself there's
only one of about 10 things I didn't do
the camera didn't work they didn't check
the camera apparently they were supposed
to check on him every 30 minutes which
is kind of ridiculous they checked on
him every minute not every 30 minutes
right
but even that they didn't do so I'm
completely perplexed as to what happened
okay let's move on we have the mooch I
don't know what happened to the moon I
love the mooch
I love the mooch too but I don't know
what's going on here off the reservation
[Laughter]
I think you have to consider a change at
the top of the ticket when someone is
acting like this he has a nihilistic way
to his personality so the minute you say
something he doesn't like he figures
that he can intimidate you like a bully
there's a pernicious evil in trying to
divide the country so he's not getting
an invite to the White House Christmas
party this year
I don't think so that's the worst thing
you can do I mean he's I don't know
what's happened to him but he he knows
president Trump personally mm-hmm and I
know him personally for 30 years right
and one of the things that pains me the
most is what he's characterized this is
a really nice man I brought five people
out to see him on front on Friday at his
fundraiser he was so nice to them they
were all of Trump supporters they walked
away and they said he's really very nice
that's what everyone says and I said why
do you know they support him right why
don't you think he's nice what
on television right somebody's not like
that mooch knows that I don't know what
he's doing there has to be some other
agenda maybe that's too much hairspray
maybe even a mage maybe raise the money
for the private equity fund oh yeah a
little tough because they're Trump
haters and I don't know it could be a PR
move but we don't know speaking of
someone that needs a PR move Joe Biden
Joe Biden apparently is forgetful as
robert muller these days he didn't
remember that he wasn't even president
during a parkland shooting watch him and
we can talk about old sleep i watch what
happened when the kids from parkland
marched up tonight and I met with him
and then they went off to up on the hill
I was vice president they went off the
hill to go into those neighborhoods all
those congressmen were like no I'm not
here I'm not here don't tell him I'm
around they're afraid of it they should
be exposed okay Joe is not VP during the
parkland shooting not a good week for
Joe I mean I think he also confused
where the two mass shootings were he
confused Teresa may with Margaret
Thatcher and then he said poor kids are
just a smart very hard very hard for the
for the big media you know the ones who
love Democrats to give up on Joe cuz I
think he's is a great white hope right I
think he's the great guy can be Trump
but it's quite obvious that Joe has
always dealt with an intellectual
disability like he's not smart so they
don't want to admit that this is the guy
who plagiarized in law school he
plagiarized as a senator because he
can't really think for himself Obama
never should have chosen his vice
president because they don't have the
intellectual capacity to be vice
president now there's obviously and I
say this I think kindly there's
obviously a cognitive impairment a
cognitive impairment how do you confuse
being with he did it for about three
minutes being with the Parkland
survivor's right you've confused him
with Sandy Hook do you think it's a
memory issue or do you think there's
there something else going I've been
watching him for the last like three
four months
something wrong because you know the
gaffes go to his two biggest
deficiencies which are age in many
people's opinion and incompetence well a
age is relative right right so Bernie
Sanders right I don't agree with Bernie
Sanders Bernie Sam Sanders the sharpest
attack high-energy yeah I drove I came
home from Washington a couple weeks ago
with Henry Kissinger Henry's
90-something Henry is still as smart as
he was thirty years ago it's not age but
some people get this earlier you know
this and he's 77 something's going on
finally here's what I really am really
worried about Jo Jo's family for the
last 40 years has made millions and
millions of dollars over Jo's public
service including his son who pull down
millions from Ukraine and billions from
China and the left-wing media won't
cover it there's something wrong there
now if Jo didn't know that it's either
delusional or he's lying you can't you
can't have a son who took down a
billion-dollar investment from China
when you were negotiating with China and
you didn't know about it particularly a
son who you're concerned about because
he got thrown out of the military for
failing to cocaine test yeah I mean I
don't know what's worse not knowing
what's going on around you either one
knowing and not doing anything about my
take on Jo always has been not very
smart nice-guy and now I have a third
one he may not be totally straight
because the family made too much money
and that offends me
crooked Jo I don't know but I the
crooked Jo or Joe didn't know they the
brother made millions the son made
millions and they were trading on his
public office there it is all right
representative Al Green you know he's
been beating the drum for impeachment
for I think since the president was
inaugurated he's come out with this new
take on impeachment it involves election
strategy listen to this if he is not
defeated in the Senate he will still run
as an impeached president and there will
be a good
people who want one of hold fundraisers
with him a good many people who won't
want to be in his company because he
will become persona non grata to a good
many of these wealthy people who are
benefiting from his bigotry so this
isn't about checks and balances this
isn't about high crimes and misdemeanors
this is about branding the president
driving his numbers down and
intimidating donors and voters into
supporting him well I think that these
Democrats who were doing this
I think they need therapy trumpet
arrangement yeah yeah it's a now I think
it's a definable mental illness and
there are a lot of psychiatrists in New
York we have more psychiatry any place
else and I would I would suggest that
they go to the psych guy available and
get help there he's been cleared three
times yeah he's my client I've never had
a client that's been cleared three times
once is usually enough right twice as
ridiculous three times he didn't collude
with the Russian right he didn't have
struck justice get over it so go after
I'm an immigration go after him on taxes
or whatever the heck but this is
ridiculous
and it's only because the media is so
set against him that they even tolerate
this well they know that it's going
nowhere in the Senate and they know the
majority of the American people don't
support impeachment so they just want to
hurt him in the house so people think oh
wow who aren't paying attention this guy
was impeached maybe I shouldn't throw
him a fundraiser
I shouldn't say politically I believe it
will backfire on them why is that
because I think the American people had
enough of it
it's I mean after the MoMA performance a
couple weeks ago the clearing of him on
both collusion and then MOA had to come
out and say basically he couldn't find
obstruction after he kind of I don't
think I confused or he lied or he what
everybody came out and corrected it he
never found obstruction what are they
doing I mean it and then he was cleared
earlier in a seven-month
counterintelligence probe of collusion
so I think the American people have have
had enough of it I think politically it
will help the president if they continue
impeachment I
Nancy Pelosi will lose the 40 seats in
the Republican districts where our
people won and she knows that that's why
she who retains a certain amount of
adult maturity understand she could not
be Speaker but I'm not sure she can
control Jerry Nadler and Jerry wants to
be on daytime television that his makeup
on but I actually think we don't have
any makeup on this is gonna go nowhere
it's gonna go it's gonna go so Nancy is
the only one that doesn't have trumped
arrangements and rumors I don't I think
Nancy is a very practical politician
whatever you think of her and I don't
agree with her politically but this is a
very smart politician she knows this is
a losing strategy she's trying very hard
to take a crazies down and I think it'll
work eventually I don't think we have to
worry about this all right Rudy Giuliani
says Nancy Pelosi is the voice of reason
well in the day I don't know if I never
thought I would say that I ran against I
mean I can't paint against her so often
but I she's a practical person that's
right all right they're not Rudy thank
you very much thank you Jeff you're
terrific by the way